en este vídeo voy a hablar sobre una
clase especial del triángulo llamada
triángulo 30 60 90 y se llama así porque
eso miden sus ángulos entonces bueno lo
que yo voy a probar en este vídeo es un
resultado bastante útil para geometría
trigonometría etcétera y entonces bueno
lo que veremos son las razones de los
lados de un triángulo de 30 60 90 que si
la hipotenusa de este triángulo tiene
longitud x recuerda que la hipotenusa es
el lado opuesto al al ángulo de 90
grados entonces si la hipotenusa tiene
longitud x lo que probaremos es que el
lado más corto es decir el ángulo
opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados tiene
longitud de x sobre 2 y que el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados estudia
kahn tendrá longitud de raíz de 3 por la
longitud del lado opuesto al ángulo más
corto es decir raíz de 3 por x sobre 2 y
esto será su longitud entonces eso vamos
a probar en este vídeo así que iniciemos
con un triángulo
dibujo yo un triángulo que nos es muy
familiar
voy a dibujar un triángulo equilátero
que no es muy fácil de dibujar pero
supongamos que lo estoy haciendo es mi
mejor intento de dibujar un triángulo
equilátero con vértices a b y c y bueno
entonces tenemos el triángulo abc
y recordemos que si es y hillá pero
entonces sus lados son iguales digamos
que es un equilátero con lados de
longitud x equilátero con lados de
longitud x es decir que si un lado vale
x si este lado vale x entonces también
este vale x y también este vale x
sabemos basado en lo que en x por lo que
sabemos de triángulos equiláteros
entonces la medida de sus ángulos
internos son iguales cierto entonces son
de 60 60 éste mide 60 y también éste
mide 60 porque 60 más 60 más 60 son 180
y bueno lo que voy a hacer a
continuación es dejar caer una altitud
desde este punto desde el vértice b
entonces bueno por definición una
altitud intersecta la base del triángulo
formando un ángulo recto tenemos aquí
ángulos rectos y esto es una prueba
bastante rápida mostrar que no solamente
es una altitud sino que este ángulo
recto también visita a la base de hecho
puedes poner pausa al vídeo y probarlo
tú mismo esto va a visitar la base es
decir que va a dividir al segmento
base en dos partes iguales entonces
vamos a llamar este punto de y tenemos
que el triángulo ave de y el triángulo
obedece ambos comparten este lado el
lado verde es común a ambos triángulos y
también todos los ángulos rectos son
iguales es uno de los postulados de
euclides por lo tanto estos dos ángulos
son iguales y entonces este ángulo es
igual a este ángulo de aquí tenemos que
si estos dos pares de ángulos son
iguales entonces estos ángulos de arriba
también son iguales entonces bueno lo
voy a marcar esto este ángulo es igual a
éste y ahora podemos usar una de
nuestras variedades de criterios de
congruencia tenemos podríamos usar el
lado ángulo lado el lado ángulo lado no
sé si lo recuerdas o podríamos usar el
criterio de ángulo lado ángulo
cualquiera de los dos funcionan y con
eso eso demuestra que el triángulo abed
es congruente al triángulo
de bebé y esto es de bastante utilidad
porque bueno como lo dije antes podemos
usar cualquiera de los dos criterios el
de ángulo lado ángulo o el de lado
ángulo lado el que más a ti te guste y
nos sirven porque con esto demostramos
que los datos correspondientes serán
iguales en particular la longitud del
lado además será igual a la longitud de
la 12da entonces a d es igual a cd y
estos son lados correspondientes
ahora si sabemos que son iguales en
longitud recordemos que este es un
triángulo equilátero de lado x entonces
cada uno de estos lados vale x sobre 2
este es también x sobre 2 y no solamente
sabemos eso también trazamos una altitud
mostramos que este ángulo debe ser
congruente a este otro ángulo y deben
sumar 60 si dos ángulos son iguales si
suman 60 entonces cada uno debe valer 30
cierto 30 y 30 y ahora bueno ya
demostramos una de las partes
interesantes de los triángulos 30 60 90
nótese que dejando caer esta altitud
esencialmente estoy partiendo al
triángulo equilátero en 2
ángulos de 30 60 90 y ya demostramos que
si el lado opuesto al ángulo recto mide
x entonces el lado opuesto al ángulo de
30 grados ese va a valer x sobre 2 y
bueno eso lo demostramos ahí arriba
ahora sólo falta demostrar cuánto vamos
a ver cuánto mide el tercer lado el lado
que está opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados
y llamemos a esta longitud bueno ya como
ya tenemos aquí las letras vader
entonces vamos a llamar a esa longitud
bbm y usaremos el teorema de pitágoras
así que bueno vamos a tener que verde al
cuadrado más x sobre 2 al cuadrado será
igual a la hipotenusa al cuadrado
entonces lo escribo acá tenemos que ver
al cuadrado más este lado al con x sobre
2 al cuadrado será igual a la hipotenusa
al cuadrado así que esto será igual a x
al cuadrado y sólo para dejar en claro
estoy observando este triángulo de aquí
donde este lado al cuadrado más este
lado al cuadrado será igual a la
hipotenusa al cuadrado
ahora que con esto hay que ver cuánto
vale vd así que desarrollamos verde al
cuadrado más x al cuadrado sobre 4 es
igual a x al cuadrado puedes visualizar
esto como 4 x al cuadrado sobre 4 es lo
mismo que x al cuadrado y si restamos un
cuarto x al cuadrado de ambos lados
obtenemos verde al cuadrado será igual a
4 x al cuadrado sobre 4 - x al cuadrado
sobre 4 eso será igual a que a 3 x al
cuadrado sobre 4 cierto así que esto es
igual a 3 x al cuadrado sobre 4 ahora
tomamos la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados
de la ecuación y obtenemos que bb es
igual a la raíz de 3 x x raíz de 3 x
raíz de x al cuadrado que es x entonces
x x sobre la raíz de 4 lo cuales dos ya
sabemos que es 2 entonces todo esto
sobre 2 y bb es el lado opuesto al
ángulo de 60 grados así que ya
terminamos encontramos que queríamos
entonces si la hipotenusa vale x el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados será de x
sobre 2
opuesto hablando de 60 grados será igual
a raíz de 3 sobre 2 por equis y
terminamos